il y a dû plutôt réussies en matière
d'accès à la baignade dans les eaux du
fleuve à montréal et aussi de l'inachevé
mais surtout il n'y en a pas beaucoup
présentement à montréal et paraît qu'il
ya 170 km de rives et qui en a seulement
cinq ans qui sont accessibles ps ont
quand même assez loin sur ces 50 km de
berges public quelques centaines de
mètres seulement sont aménagés pour la
baignade à la plage urbaine de verdun au
parc naturel du cap saint jacques ainsi
qu'au parc jean-drapeau des milliers de
baigneurs profitent des installations
ceux qui souhaitent en faire autant au
parc de la promenade bellerive le font à
leurs risques et périls
c'est pas tous les endroits qui sont
faciles d'accès il ya beaucoup de roche
beaucoup d'érosion donc les aménagements
qu'ils avaient fait à l'époque qui ont
quand même été détruits ont pour aller
faire un tour dans tout sur les gros
rochers qui ont déboulé violent bergeron
et l'architecte paysagiste daniel
chartier milite depuis des décennies
pour compléter le travail on voit pas le
fleuve on devrait voir le fleuve là le
but principal c'est d'avoir accès visuel
et faisait conflore c'est ça qui devrait
être le but principal de ce parc là et
le projet de plage est sur pause
d'autres projets sont sur la table a
lâché de la mairesse de l'arrondissement
maiava danowicz est mis sur la
récupération de l'ancienne marina
beaucoup comme ça se fait en europe sur
les rivières et les lacs urbain alors
des grands qui est aménagée ou de à
partir de lesquelles les gens vont
pouvoir sauter se baigner le site al
avantage de bénéficier d'une eau propre
et profonde le projet fera prochainement
l'objet d'une consultation publique et
pourrait voir le jour dans cinq ans ici
louis de belleval radio canada montréal